good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight as if this country's
core institutions have not been degraded
or diminished enough with pregnant
flight suits and fbi that behaves like
nancy pelosi's praetorian guard as if
that weren't bad enough
joe biden announced in january his plan
to choose the next supreme court justice
on the basis of appearance the supreme
court
you never thought that would happen
sociology department may be your company
perhaps
but the supreme court really matters
what does appearance have to do with
ability or fealty to the constitution
joe biden never explained he'd indicate
to be fair that he would prefer a lawyer
for the job maybe even a clever one but
mostly he said he wanted a black woman
genetics being the single most important
factor in what we used to call judicial
temperament how does that work exactly
how do genes determine your ability as a
supreme court justice or a surgeon or an
airline pilot or anything else
we would love to hear joe biden explain
that but he didn't
instead he embarked on a predictably
short nationwide search for such a
candidate and located in the end a
person called kentaji brown jackson her
confirmation hearings continued today
for the second day not surprisingly
given how she got this job most of the
talk in washington was not about what
she's done how she thinks what she's
like as a person but instead about how
she looks
it's not shallow or anything here's the
shallowest of all senator cory booker of
new jersey
i could not stop being just joyous that
you were sitting in my office and i
couldn't stop bringing up to you the
historical nature of this forgive me i
grew up in a small black church where i
was taught to make a joyous noise unto
the lord and this is not a normal day
for america
we have never had this moment before
i grew up in a small black jerk maiden
another lecture about the black
experience from a blue-eyed yale
graduate who in fact grew up in an
all-white town the son of ibm executives
is there anyone on this planet phonier
than cory booker
der her credit can dodgy brown jackson
doesn't seem quite so fraudulent that
would be impossible but she does and
this is the key share a resume that is
strikingly similar to cory bookers
daughter of academics graduate of
harvard college and harvard law school
on the board of the single wokest day
school in washington dc etc etc you know
exactly how that story turns out
because in the end when they tell you
you're getting a black nominee they're
not talking about the son of a maid and
a farm worker from pinpoint georgia in
fact we already have a supreme court
justice like that his name is clarence
thomas he's a great man even if no one
in washington will acknowledge that no
what they mean when they tell you you're
getting a black supreme court justice is
that you're getting yet another
democratic party robot with the same
rigid and totally predictable views as
your average professional class white
liberal
but who happens to be tanner than joe
biden so identical identical to everyone
else in power just a different shade
and the shade to be fair does make all
the difference that's the whole point of
the exercise because of the way that she
looks brown jackson who again is just a
garden variety white liberal
in what she believes
but because the way she looks this
nominee will get nowhere near the
vetting of a typical supreme court
justice and that whatever your politics
are is a shame
as ruth marcus of the washington post
put it four years ago when democrats
were baselessly accusing a republican
nominee of rape quote when a supreme
court seat is on the line the court and
the country deserve the benefit of the
doubt not the nominee
all right we're kind of on board with
that actually but that was yesterday's
standard
today not surprisingly that same
newspaper jeff bezos's personal
newspaper announced a new position
the post put it this way in a headline
how low will the gop go when ticking on
kentucky brown jackson
pretty funny
it's low to ask questions of a supreme
court nominee
but we're not deterred we believe in
standards on this show the supreme court
of course one of the most powerful
institutions in the world joe biden did
not create the supreme court previous
generations did hundreds of years ago he
does not own it he merely inherited it
for a short time and so the rest of us
have an interest in who sits on it and
who interprets our constitution
joe biden sounding maybe a touch
defensive has described kintaji brown
jackson as one of this country's great
legal minds and we certainly want to
believe that for for real given that
she's probably going to be confirmed no
matter what we think the question is is
it true is she really one of this
country's great legal minds
one way to know one indication would be
her lsct scores
the lsat is not a knowledge test it
measures logic and reasoning ability and
no one doubts it's an accurate measure
of those things which predicts legal
skills and that's why top law firms law
schools have long used that test
so how did kintaji brown jackson do in
the lsat sorry
you're not allowed to ask because asking
is racism watch
after judge jackson's name was announced
so is contangi brown jackson tucker
carlson on his fox news program ignored
her nearly nine years on the federal
bench and instead wondered about her
scores on the lsat you do not hear
substantive legal arguments about her
actual decision-making process coming
from these people all they've got is the
racism they want to go about the lsat
scores i'm not going to curse because
it's sunday and i'd get fired but can
you talk about why what tucker carlson
just said is so
repugnant and they have implied you were
solely nominated due to your race and
not for other factors
apparently some have even claimed that
you need to show your lsat scores
to determine whether you are a top legal
mind this is incredibly offensive and
condescending
it's repugnant it's incredibly offensive
she's a top legal mind shut up
we don't have to show you proof you're
not allowed to ask for proof
it's hilarious so here you've got maisie
hirono the senate's dumbest member we
don't need to ask for her test scores we
know what they are
she's infuriated that anyone would
suggest that judge jackson was nominated
because of a race and sex after joe
biden bragged repeatedly that judge
jackson was nominated for her race and
sex
it's too funny
they demand that you listen to them very
carefully but they become apoplectic if
you dare to repeat what they say what's
the message here shut up you're not
allowed to talk no more insulin surf
sorry not playing along
thankfully in the hearings today a few
centers did manage to ask relevant
questions here's josh hawley
united states versus hawkins
this was a child pornography case where
the defendant distributed multiple
images of child porn possessed dozens
more including videos
the federal sentencing guidelines
recommended a sentence of 97 to 121
months in prison
prosecutors recommended 24 months in
prison
judge jackson gave the defendant three
months in prison
well that's pretty serious why did you
do that judge jackson
well here was the response
the guideline was based originally on
a statutory scheme and on directives
specific directives by congress at a
time
in which
more serious child pornography
offenders were identified based on
the volume
based on the number of photographs that
they received in the mail and that made
totally total sense
before
when we didn't have the internet when we
didn't have distribution but the way
that the guideline is now structured
based on that set of circumstances
is leading to extreme disparities in the
system
because
it's so easy for people to get
volumes of this kind of material now
by
computers now we'll just concede up
front we are not world renowned legal
minds okay or even technically lawyers
on this show but we're going to try to
understand what the judge just said so
congress passed a law saying possessing
a lot of kitty porn is a very serious
crime and then an invention the internet
comes along and makes it easier to
collect a lot more kiddie porn
so according to noted legal mind kentaji
brown jackson that somehow makes the act
of possessing a lot of kitty porn less
bat in other words since the internet
makes it simple we're not going to
punish you as much
maybe we're misinterpreting what she
said that seems to be what she said does
that make sense
if not it helps to understand in the
clip you just saw that judge brown was
not articulating some legal principle
related to the constitution that we
could generalize across our code
she was instead constructing a carve out
for a narrow and specific group of
criminals sex offenders
and it's not the first time it's one of
many such carve-outs she has argued for
during her career
in 1996 for example kataji brown jackson
argued in the harvard law review against
sex offender registry laws here was her
reasoning quote if a community
notification statute deprives the sex
offender of his right to mobility or
bodily integrity and if it makes him the
target of widespread community reaction
and typically in scorn then according to
contagio brown jackson
that would be unconstitutional
why is it unconstitutional she didn't
explain is that a sound legal argument
and why is judge jackson so fixated on
defending sexual predators what does the
fbi think of that well funny you asked
about the fbi this show has just
obtained an email from the fbi's los
angeles women and black affairs
committee that's some group within the
fbi you're seeing on your screen right
now
this was sent out to every fbi agent in
the fbi's la field office on march 11th
this month it is an invitation to quote
a nomination party for kentangi brown
jackson join us for quote lots of
celebrating the invitation reads now the
party was set for march 23rd that's
tomorrow in an fbi conference room
christy coons johnson the assistant
director in charge of the la field
office is the featured speaker huh
this is a nominee
this is someone who doesn't have the job
whose nomination is by definition a
political question the senate votes on
it that's in the constitution by the way
and the fbi is weighing in with both
feet on their choice which is kentucky
brown jackson
so we should tell you the next day the
fbi's diversity and inclusion office
issued what it called an update
quote the fbi must remain neutral in all
political nomination and confirmation
processes accordingly a party for any
nominee in fbi space would be
inappropriate we apologize for any
misunderstanding surrounding the
publicity for this event
misunderstanding certainly in public not
that we did it
but that you somehow misunderstood the
publicity right no we didn't there was
no publicity we just read the invitation
the update included a new flyer for the
same party that removed any mention of
brown jackson it's not a
misunderstanding
they just said out loud what everyone
already knows the fbi is a political
force and is decided there on the side
of contagion brown jackson
so if you've got the white house and the
congress and the fbi are three main
power centers behind kentucky brown
jackson she'll probably get the job
sorry but we'd still like to see your
lct score hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else